foreign
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
happy New Year dude
um annoying starting the year off
annoying his [ __ ] you know um welcome
actually let me start with this man I
just got news that
um Jeremy Renner look we're you know I
love Jeremy Renner there's no uh that's
no secret we love
we love Jeremy Renner and this podcast
and uh he's a great actor and he's
phenomenal and uh he was in a snow plow
accident and this is not a joke uh
you'll probably have heard the news
maybe you have maybe you haven't I don't
know how Savvy you are uh with news but
he uh is in a he was he was I guess
maybe the information I was told was he
was run over by some sort of snow plow
uh vehicle and um that he's in critical
but stable positions
um condition which I have no idea what
critical and stable
why can't why do I want to say position
uh condition
I don't know what critical but stable
condition is but critical and stable
condition sounds
critical right like that's doing the
heavy lifting you know it's like um
you know if you put peanut butter on
something you don't know you know that
peanut butter is in the [ __ ] shits
right it's not like this kind of thing
where it's like oh but the the main
thing is though also there's pineapple
and we like that no absolutely not the
shit's full of peanut butter if it's got
a little bit of peanut butter in it now
um Jeremy Renner is in critical but
stable position I
stay in position dude and I know I'm not
even on the [ __ ] Gabapentin right now
I'm on a lot of other meds um but yeah
dude I I just
um I don't know how he is by the time
this comes out there might be more
information on it and I really hope and
pray
um you know I've been trying to get in
and get into praying lately uh that
um
Jeremy Renner is doing okay because our
heart goes out to him and we love him
here at the congratulations on the
congratulations podcast and um I really
hope that he's okay dude he's Hawkeye
he's got to get that Arrow flying
um so yeah so that's I hope that it's
okay
um and also like And subscribe you know
how they you know how we do it
sh you know how they do it here on
[ __ ] super code Studios Shadow band
City
um but yeah so we're probably gonna have
to change the name because that I mean
you know I don't know what the [ __ ]
going on so maybe drop some comments on
what we should call it uh but yeah dude
uh Happy New Year you know plant and all
that [ __ ] how we do it very annoying um
how I was doing it on lifeline and all
that [ __ ] and uh just appreciate another
year it's 2023 and
um and we're living large right we're
living large we're we're making sure
everything is good we're making sure
everybody is happy it's gonna be a you
know I don't know what the [ __ ] gonna
be going on honestly with the um you
know here's the thing dude like you
think about I heard that Trump was gonna
run again or whatever really don't you
know at this point Biden and you know we
get political but at this point Biden ah
what is he doing right yeah he's not
doing yeah
ah you fall off a bike you're done
right president
the President right I'm not saying we
should like you know absolutely remove
his head if he's a citizen but you want
to lead the
Nation you follow Mike yeah right oh
wrapped up he should have been like this
all good take his tie off here you go to
whoever the [ __ ]
um
uh but yeah so and obviously that's old
news that he fell off the bike but um
yeah so I don't know what the [ __ ]
gonna be going on in 2024 when the when
the election happens again but uh that
is something I've been thinking about
because now you know Trump is back on
Twitter and all that [ __ ] and they
reinstated uh you know all the shits
and Andrew Tate that's his name right
Andrew uh who got arrested recently
um and it is still only on Twitter
because elon's holding strong on
everybody gets to be on Twitter and he's
off Instagram and and Facebook and I
don't know what the [ __ ] guys what's
going on here who knows what's real and
who knows what's not real the whole
world's a mess
dude the whole world's a mess and
[ __ ] Hawkeye got run over by a snow
plow so it's all good dude that's where
we're at dude 2023 started with Hawkeye
getting run over by snowplow you
understand
so uh we hope that everything's uh okay
with everybody honestly dude I I just um
you know
uh uh I really really uh I don't know I
[ __ ] who knows what's happening all I
know is I've been really watching Dr
Miami and that's the [ __ ] I don't
understand Dr Miami because I don't
understand
this whole thing about look
I've been watching it it's on Hulu you
know Hulu is the thing that like I
mainly watch you probably don't know
that but I'm telling you that now uh and
I've been watching Dr Miami
and this guy is a guy who got big on
Tick Tock I guess is what Kristen said
and and then
uh became a guy who has a TV show which
is cool I guess I don't even know if
that's backwards now at this point
though right like everybody wanted to
get a TV show and I still did that I
still think that's the thing but like
even thinking about like Calvin my son
when I when when he wants to watch
[ __ ] YouTube
I mean he's he's been getting into
Teletubbies a little bit which is on
Netflix he calls it Teletubbies which is
cute as [ __ ]
dude and he also says he also says we
say like how do you feel and for some
reason they'll just be like I'm nervous
dude it's so cute that he says he's
nervous and I say why are you nervous
and he says I'm nervous
it's cute dude
and then he says I'm frustrated oh God
damn he's grown up before my eyes you
know as they say he's grown up over my
eyes
and we love him dude
and we and we grow together right
um and he's at a cut on his [ __ ] nose
for [ __ ] two and a half weeks because
he can't stop picking it but anyway uh
watching Dr Miami and is in my son I
think well you know he's two and a half
he's almost three but
he want he wants to watch the the [ __ ]
which is just accessible and that's on
YouTube now I get like Netflix and
Hulu's all that [ __ ] but like I try to
watch a cooking show big food uh what
the hell is it called big food bucket
list
and uh you know because Calvin's kind of
into cooking a little bit but he wants
he wants the YouTube shits you know
so uh yeah I watch Dr Miami and this guy
is now doing this is the problem with
doing the the the the the shows from
Tick Tock and from Instagram and all
this [ __ ] they're trying to make it like
Tick Tock which it's not that it's a
show but this guy is now on Hulu and
he's like doing the [ __ ] that he does on
Tick Tock where he's like hey and he's
wearing a wig for no [ __ ] reason
meeting a a patient and he's like so
we're gonna take that uh that lump off
your nose and he's got like a Pippi
Longstocking wig on and it's like okay
but also this is surgery right so it's
different if you're doing it for tick
tock than if you are actually
interviewing the people that you're
gonna give a BBL
in a fireman's outfit right and then
they got the dads dude there was one
episode where they were so Italian dude
I I really feel like Italians
speak to me you know and I know that I'm
Italian and I come from that [ __ ] like
look I have a cousin Butch I gotta cut
some Butch baby I got an uncle Vinnie
right like these are my this is my blood
dude
um
so I really love the Italian like I
don't feel that connection with southern
people but I wish I did because I love
southern people right but I love I love
specific people right like if somebody
is saying something about like hey man I
got a [ __ ] landscaping business or
something like I'm from [ __ ] Tulsa I
got a landscaping business I'm like
that's so specific that guy is
immediately my best friend because I
love it right I don't know anybody with
a landscape business you love front
Lawns bro
if you love front Lawns and you're from
Tulsa I'm in right
I'm in
because what the [ __ ] is that oh you're
passionate about it I'm in
okay you want to talk about planting
hibiscus or whatever the [ __ ] all the
dude I am so in number one
I'm in because I'm in because I can't
believe you want to talk about that so
much and I love your passion and it
bleeds from you but also we don't have
to talk about me my baby right so
um
that's very hard for me to talk about
myself and I'm learning and I'm getting
through it right
a lot of stuff that went on in childhood
wasn't necessarily uh you know maybe
you're gonna put the walls up from what
um
but yeah so uh
I don't know why I started talking about
all this from Dr Miami but uh oh
Italians this woman wanted to come in to
talk about
um
wanted to come in to get a note the
people who are like come in and do all
the plastic surgeries at once God bless
dude right like just going in and coming
out just straight up a different person
God bless
I understand you don't want to keep
going in because you don't want to keep
getting knocked out and [ __ ]
obliterated with your you know but
this woman got a liposuction you know
her her boobs different and then like a
BBL and a nose job which means you're
gonna have to [ __ ] turn the person
over in the middle of it
I don't know how they do that honestly
because it's got to be bad for like the
healing process but anyway
the dad was so Italian he was like your
beautiful nose what are you gonna do
that's my face on your face it was Essa
chauvinistic
he's talking about like not you know you
want to change your face I'm happy
you're happy but that's how everybody
knows you he literally said that
everybody knows you with that wart on
your nose
worst thing to be known for
that what is how people know who you are
bad
get it removed
that's my nose on your face there it
breaks my heart he was dude he was
crying he was crying in the [ __ ] room
to the side and and the guy was talking
and by the way they're filming the
episode but also Dr Miami's doing this
to the guy's face
like like
yo they got the cameras but then they go
to like Dr Miami's this is what the
thing that [ __ ] Hollywood thinks like
oh yeah let's do it also from we'll get
the tick tock engagement with the [ __ ]
dude and it's like did they man the
cameras were there
it's like when people are at my shows by
the way I'll be in San Diego on Sunday
and Seattle and Portland and all this
[ __ ] you know and Brea in California so
go to chrisley.com but
they they uh
he's like I just don't know you know it
breaks my heart because that's who she
is and it's just like that that that
makes my that makes our jeans just like
she's disappearing uh jeans are
disappearing and he's crying dude and
he's got a [ __ ] bowling shirt on
stallion
um well people know you from your water
you knows stallion dude
she looks like a witch get it removed
had a bowling shirt on guess if he was
fat or not don't have to
um
so yeah anyway she came out looking
fantastic you know that's how they do it
dude I like when people say they get
plastic surgery for themselves I guess
they do right but also
nah that's that's also not true though
you know what I mean it's great to get
plastic surgery for yourself and I get
it but also hey no right
you got it for yourself
you get a painting where do you hang it
behind the clothes in the closet what do
you do huh he's showing it off dude
um there was another one where a guy was
like where a woman wanted a breast
reduction and the dude was
dude her boyfriend was so trying to hold
it together dude
he was just like yeah you know
um I don't know you know it's just like
um it's not her though and they were
like well yeah but her boobs are fake
and they're like yeah yeah
um yeah yeah no I know but it's like
that's her to me you know what I'm
saying
yeah and she was like but I need to do
this for myself and he was like yeah
yeah no no yeah not like
I know you know what I'm saying but like
the you know what I'm saying like the
how do I say this
the squirt engagement you know what I'm
saying
like just was so worried about himself
I don't I don't know you know you gotta
she was like but they hurt my back he
was like yeah yeah yeah no no I mean
you're not saying yeah but you know what
I'm saying
um
the boner inducement you know what I'm
saying
um so
anyway they got the the she got him re
uh reduced and the and the doctor was
like would you like to come in during
the surgery and the guy was like yeah I
think I would and he went into the
surgery and he dude he goes in with the
with the mask on took the mask off in
the surgery
septic and then left and didn't talk to
her for two days wasn't there when she
woke up
dude like and then came back and it was
all good and he was like sorry I made a
mistake and it was like
I'll do it uh
so
um but yeah dude so anyway this is what
it is
we watch TV do it or the breaker watch
TV and also you know yeah it's uh
you know actually I went to [ __ ]
nobody knows about this but I went to
rehab
um and I I don't know if I was gonna
tell people this or not but I did I go I
went to rehab I was there for over a
month I went back in November and um we
pre-record a lot of the [ __ ]
um and
just should have done it this whole time
honestly like should have done it years
ago didn't because I had excuses in my
head about covet and [ __ ] but uh and all
that and uh but yeah the uh
I did it because I I had to you know for
for uh my addiction and all that [ __ ]
and I I need to be present and but my
God it was a trauma-based thing that I
uh I went to and um
one of the best in the world and holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] man
really uh
the work that they do there is
absolutely amazing dude I I was there
and I was scared of [ __ ] and I thought
that
um everybody when I was there two weeks
in after I stopped being scared of [ __ ]
I was like oh everybody should do this
dude
because you do [ __ ] where like you sit
in a chair and close your eyes and talk
dude who do you think you talk to man
who do you think you talk to think about
it who do you think you talk to
think about it you're probably like oh
your mom or oh your dad or friends or
enemies or people from your past and I
would be like yeah
but then they're like but then you're
like oh yeah oh you probably talked to
also
maybe who else you talk to your friends
your mom your dad you know your brother
you talk to friends you talk to people
that wronged you you talk to people
you're wrong oh yeah yeah yeah but you
know who else you talk to
you close your eyes and you talk to you
as a seven-year-old
[Music]
oh [ __ ] dude when I did that
[Music]
foreign
that's the
the water the floods just you dude
coming from the
how will the the doctor how old are you
when you imagine yourself as a child I
don't know like seven and where are you
what do you mean where are you as a
seven-year-old
if you were gonna if you as a 42 year
old were gonna walk up and talk to
yourself as a seven-year-old where would
you be
like this though
I don't know my old front porch
dude
was in the trance
I wasn't here's the thing man I wasn't
hypnotized but dude the [ __ ] tears
bro and
it was
it was it was transformative dude it was
so unbelievable dude
um
yeah
and I'm I'm I met so many great people
dude
foreign
yeah it was it was
it was crazy to
um
think about
every day being here
yeah in November uh through December and
it was just like
I don't know what to say about it man
food was trash
the food was [ __ ] trash get it
together
um the food was trash it was little
literally like from like my little
kitchen where you're like do you eat
this part
um but yeah man
you know a lot of those guys in there um
obviously like you know you don't share
names and [ __ ] but like my God they were
just like the the most
uh to make lifelong friends at 42 and
already know about it
like a weekend just like these are these
are my people it's hilarious too like
because like when you're when you're an
addict you're also yourself do you know
what I'm talking about you're you're
you're also yourself
so
what I went in as myself what I thought
right and and like you're like all right
I'm gonna go to this thing now I have an
unbelievable amount of fear in my life
I have an unbelievable amount of fear in
my life
ever since I was a little kid
just every second in my head is
something my you know somebody's gonna
abduct my parents somebody's gonna kill
my dad somebody's gonna poison me right
just been there from as early as I can
remember did not sleep through the night
in my bed until I was maybe
13 like I would run into my parents room
like just being honest with you guys
like running my parents room my dad
would come and be like you gotta go to
sleep whatever dude just terrified of
everything and
um
you go in with the tapes that play in
your head you know of
I got this but I also secretly don't
have this because I'm scared because
like I'm lonely I think I'm not worthy
of love and like
whatever it is and I think I'm not uh
uh important
do I matter you know the real the
negative core beliefs that you have of
yourself and you go in and you think uh
but I'm I'm me I'm different I'm you
know that whole that that's poison to
think that you're different or above it
all or whatever the [ __ ] it is but you
walk in that way and then when you walk
in with that fear me me I should say me
when I walk in with that fear and that
all that compartmentalization and all
that stuff that I've been working with
and working on for 42 years to build my
[ __ ] walls up
um
you just walk in and you see the other
dudes who just they just they you know
what they look like
people
they're just people they're people that
you might see
you know where somewhere
somewhere somewhere on the way somewhere
or maybe at the place
right
or on the news somewhere talking about
some [ __ ] you know parade that
they're yeah I'm really happy about that
that guy is there
and some people look
cool some people look not cool some
people look fashionable not fashionable
some people look sad some people are
joking around and you walk in and you
just go I you have this I had this
thought where I was just I walked in and
I was just like oh
I'm like this
right you walk in with all that baggage
and then
you will see everyone else you see a guy
with like a a [ __ ] um uh a
Beijing soccer team jersey on
and then a tall guy from Kenya who's
like six foot 19.
with Patagonia on and you're like oh
ah
I'm like this though
and those were my [ __ ] people
dude
I didn't want to well I don't know if I
didn't want to talk about it but it's
just it just went on it's it's what's
happening in my life and
it's so important to me you know
and I and I and I love those guys and
and the therapy there dude was
I mean
it was like
it was like the therapists take their
heart out put it on the front of their
boots
and kick in the [ __ ] teeth for hours
a day
that's what it's like
they take their heart they take their
blood they take their tears from
whatever they've been working with
because a lot of them were addicts too
or our addicts and they just take their
heart out you go you sit in a chair they
put their heart on the [ __ ] tip of
their Boot and they just go sit tight
and [ __ ] just
just kick in the goddamn teeth and it is
the most
painful beautiful thing
and it's necessary and it's hard
um yeah
it uh it just something I should have
done a long time ago and I and I didn't
and uh I did
and uh
I I I I I can't
express enough that if you are
an addict or whatever it is even if you
think you got it
you know what I'm talking about even if
you think I got this or even if you've
had it it's so hard to make
um
it's so hard to make
a a it a priority
Mental Health
um
and doing it
moving life you know to do it
for me it's just it was too important
man like
I I
know I come on here I'm this funny guy
but like
you know
like I I get these [ __ ]
you know suicidal ideation and [ __ ] like
that and it's just I
the
you have to keep that [ __ ] in check and
I [ __ ] I cry on [ __ ] podcast all
the goddamn time but
whatever
um so you have to get
you have it's just such a good idea man
and and it was so cool to hear the
therapists and how much they care about
you and they they keep in touch with me
now for [ __ ] sake
um
you know I heard that the guys in there
miss me now
so
but that [ __ ] Dr Miami thing man is
just like he's so annoying
and dude everybody
knew what
Love You Like That
whether it's plastic surgery or [ __ ]
you know
[ __ ] is struggling [ __ ] is a [ __ ]
you know it's all about growth
if you ain't growing you're dying that's
what I'm gonna run for when I'm a mayor
the mayor of [ __ ]
uh so I don't know dude
the whole [ __ ]
yeah I don't know man well whatever [ __ ]
it but uh I love you [ __ ]
uh I love y'all love y'all
um
yeah
but didn't have [ __ ] my uh
dude I like to go to zany Island I like
to take the I like to be the vivance boy
didn't have that for for [ __ ] didn't
have it dude how about this
how about me gently oh you're thinking
of Chris how'd it go in there oh yeah
the [ __ ] yeah he's wearing his own
clothes but he's probably still got the
[ __ ] four shots of espresso dude they
don't let you have coffee
you gotta wake up at 6 00 a.m for
meditation
on your own dude with your brain and
that's it
you get used to it after over 10 days
you get used to it okay
the first 10 days you get headaches
it's like a [ __ ]
it's like a Mack truck hit you in the
goddamn in the head and you wake up and
you go the set that second day that
third day you wake up and you go usually
oh
oh
and then you go in and you say can I get
actually can I get some uh Advil oh we
actually have you know when like you're
like whatever you want whatever it is
you want by the way I don't know what
the [ __ ] the difference is between
ibuprofen aspirin Tylenol day I don't
know dude but no matter who I ask they
never have the [ __ ] one I want dude
hey do you have Advil oh no but I
actually have have you ever heard of
[ __ ] what this it's the same thing
it's it's not it doesn't have ibuprofen
in it but it's got the what what if it
doesn't have a proven in it how does it
help what
isn't that the thing
I got no idea I got no idea
I have no idea taking it to say dude
when I was there though in rehab they
would give me the [ __ ] here this fine
I'm dude there's a [ __ ]
sun rising in my head or give it to me
give it to me it would tamper it a
little bit but you'd have to go through
like red tape to get [ __ ] except
whatever Bayer or Excedrin or some [ __ ]
and then [ __ ] halfway through they
were like do you want the thing for your
headache with the caffeine or without
and I was like this is for
this is for me headaches give me the
caffeine
why was the nurse hot
[ __ ] God damn it that was gonna be funny
whatever dude don't have hot nurses in
rehab
always a struggle
um yeah dude so uh
oh it's a struggle but yeah so um
yeah man
it's all good
I think I want to have some of these
[ __ ] mental health professionals on
my podcast and [ __ ] dude the stuff that
they would talk about was amazing but
anyway dude decaf coffee for [ __ ] I
drank decaf coffee the whole time
and uh
and uh yeah dude finally got over the
headaches got out and then got a coffee
took a few sips and I was like not for
me dude what now I gotta drink hot
coffee in the morning
I guess it's better they said it's
better for anxiety but your boy still
anxious as [ __ ]
but your boy though
and now he's off the [ __ ] zany and
off the
was never really on it but you know
occasionally I take the Zanny took a
zany the other day dude oh
I go like this well I guess maybe I can
eight and a half hours later
yo when you do that if you don't take
some [ __ ] ever you don't take anything
for that dopamine hit dude I didn't even
masturbate with the whole time I was
there
zero dopamine hits zero I didn't know
what was going on with Kanye West
didn't have my phone
zero dopamine hits
first time I talked to my wife two weeks
in
just [ __ ] I'm coming up
I want the world to know I hung up I'm
coming up oh I want the dude it was for
real honestly when I talked to my wife
two weeks in
after not talking
you know what it was like dude
dinner oh yeah that's right this [ __ ]
I forgot about this this internet
doesn't work
um what's the [ __ ] uh
gonna be a commercial because I'm not
signed in
it's great
I hung up the phone I just go like this
dude I I just I don't I don't
That Dope that was I'm codependent
I'm Co I'm codependent
something I learned
still this dude I uh
codependent is going to get your
uh
uh acceptance
from someone else the way they feel and
they were they react yeah yes dude I
have that
yourself forth is based off what other
people think of you yes I have that
obviously you probably already know that
because I'm a stand-up comedian didn't
know that though because beef walls up
dude
well now I really know it and it sucks
but it is what it is and uh
uh you know let me go to CODA meetings I
got meetings for [ __ ] everything they
got Workaholics Anonymous they got
[ __ ] all sorts of anonymouses dude
and all they do is like change the one
word in it
um but yeah dude
um yeah I talked to my wife and holy
[ __ ] that dude I felt like I was in
Castaway that's what it was like at the
end when Tom Hanks is in the middle of
the [ __ ] roads and he's talking to
Helen Hunt and it's like even though
they ruined the [ __ ] Pre movie in the
previews
because you saw him meeting her at the
end why do they do that with the preview
of The [ __ ] Castaway preview don't
show that part in the preview only show
the plane crash and then his beard all
big and the soccer ball or whatever the
[ __ ] it is Henley the [ __ ] volleyball
Stanley what the [ __ ] is it Wilson right
because it's a Wilson volleyball and uh
so yeah so [ __ ]
uh
yeah man it was awesome
hey what's up you know dude we didn't
even get to [ __ ] watch the only thing
that we could do is watch uh DVDs
on Friday and Saturday night
otherwise this is what we did dude
besides crying and getting our heart
kicked our [ __ ] teeth kicked in with
the with hearts
the [ __ ] only thing we would do is
this
you ever been dude you ever been
chilling
I guess what no the answer is no not
maybe if you're above older than me
nobody [ __ ] chills anymore
I go to my phone for that dopamine hit
dude nah not anymore can't do it
I go to my phone I go to my I [ __ ] go
I go to Fantasy in my head for that
dopamine hit
no I don't do that anymore
I mean I have to stop myself sometimes
to get a sex with past sexual partners
and [ __ ] like that that will be my
Escape dude because I don't want to
think about me it goes back to
why I like talking to [ __ ]
landscapers about how many pots they're
planning the plants they're putting
because I don't because I don't pots are
planning too because I don't want to
have to talk about me sad
but dude it's all from childhood you
know
those negative tapes that play in your
head that [ __ ] is absolutely something
that you cannot
I don't know man
you gotta deal with it
so I'm trying and it's tough uh but yeah
anyway
that we watch [ __ ] DVDs I saw Hunger
Games
um
sat and watched a movie without my phone
saw uh Hunger Games saw um
oh dude
bro the funniest thing the hardest I
laughed the whole time there was a guy
there that was uh of a religion of a
religion that doesn't let them
um [ __ ] hold on I gotta plug my my
headphones in
of a religion that doesn't watch like uh
like the Amish you know they don't have
[ __ ] they like churn butter and he was
there and dude he got there and it was
like movie night one night and he was
like oh awesome and so we watched porn
Supremacy
and he was do just like
the the screen was here and just
watching the people like
at the end of the movie one of the dudes
says oh do you like that movie and he
says [ __ ] yeah dude and he was like and
they were like oh you've never seen
you've never seen the Bourne movies
before dude
he said I've never seen any movies
dude
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] dude he said I've
never seen any movies bro we fell out
it was the funniest [ __ ] thing dude
it was the funniest goddamn thing
um
like also the fact that his first movie
he saw was born too
um
yeah dude so much funny [ __ ] [ __ ] but
anyway uh yeah
but that uh dopamine hit is real man
gotta keep that in check I do at least
uh
[ __ ] yeah I love that song dude
um I uh
I love Calvin dude I got home saw my
wife and Calvin
it was just the greatest
um
you know
it's crazy to be a dad and see my my son
and know that to see things in my son
that I was like he is so sensitive and I
I am so [ __ ] sensitive dude like I I
as I said I was scared of everything I
thought my parents were gonna get
abducted and [ __ ] like that and like I
thought I was being poisoned
slowly as a kid I thought my friend's
mom was going to poison me I mean just
like all sorts of [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
that I believed I actually believed it
wasn't like something that I was scared
of I thought it was happening
every day was the end of the world for
me when I was a kid
and uh
yeah and um
and so I see Calvin and he's just I see
him be so you know sensitive and I just
I don't want to make the same [ __ ] I
don't want him to have
the bad parts you know
um
but
you're gonna [ __ ] up your kid no matter
what that's the thing that's the [ __ ]
hardest truth you know
and the things also that your parents
fall short on
aren't even their fault a lot of the
times I mean of course if they're
beating the [ __ ] out of you it is but
like
to hold space for people that to for to
hold space for both things things that
you didn't get as a child that you
needed from your parents
and the fact that you still love them
and it's not their fault it's just those
two things together are something that I
really struggled with you know
um
because it's just going to happen no
matter what so I do also because I live
in fear get so scared of [ __ ] Calvin
and uh you know [ __ ] him up
um but I just love that boy so much man
um I love my family so much and it's
just uh
the first thing he said to me when I got
back was he looked at me and he goes
like this we call his we call his
grandma my my wife's mom Kiki first
thing he said was he looks at me because
he woke up from it from a nap or
uh in the morning right yeah in the
morning I woke up and and he looks at me
and he goes he looks at me and he sees
it's me and he goes like this
let's go see kick his toys
and I was just like that is the [ __ ]
funniest sweetest thing and I said let's
see dude and then I he was like so like
showing off and being excited and I was
just the happiest
I was just the happiest man
um
yeah so I did take a break because of my
mental health
um and that was why and
um
I do feel a bit refreshed
and I am excited for my shows I haven't
performed in a bit
is going to be a bit of a [ __ ] memory
game
um but yeah been trying to potty train
Calvin which is really [ __ ] hilarious
uh he just
he'll go he'll go on the little potty
you know we got that little potty and
[ __ ]
for him uh I [ __ ] in there too it's a
mess no I don't and um
here's a little potty and he sits on it
and he waits to pee and he's just like
waiting and then he'll he'll go it'll go
and it'll jump up and as he jumps up
he'll go I did it and piss all over the
floor also and I'm like uh dude you're
doing such a good job dude you are doing
such a good job but you got to stay
there on the on the toilet and he does
again he does a little bit more stands
up as he's I did it and I'm like I got
piss all over me I'm just like you're
doing such a good job dude
you are doing such a good job you gotta
stay on there I'm pooping I'm like
that's actually pee but you're doing it
dude
and then and then he's like I have to
poop and he goes on there sits on the
toilet for 25 minutes doesn't poop and
I'm just wasting time dude but I'm not
though because you know I'm teaching
them how to party how to be potty
trained but it's so [ __ ] cute and so
funny dude I'll actually sit there with
him all [ __ ] day dude I don't get
bored we chat we talk about [ __ ]
different things I mean mostly it's
[ __ ] because he's leading it but
like dude it's stuff that you know what
it's important to him how about that how
about maybe that's what he needs
so if he wants to talk about [ __ ]
purple crayons for way too long which he
does sometimes we talk about purple
crayons if you want to say it's crayon
day even though he's using a highlighter
then you know what it's [ __ ] crayon
day dude
um but he'll just sit there he hasn't
pooped in there yet but um you know
he'll pee in there sometimes and we'll
take the thing and we'll and we'll walk
it over to the toilet dump it out and
then it'll go he'll go bye peepee
and that'll run back over there
I can run back over to the toilet
um but yeah dude
I went in last night he he was he was up
till I mean put him in bed at maybe nine
something
maybe ten you know he sleeps late
because he's comic hours
um but
he uh
he he didn't have his blanket he was
still bucking around for until like 12
30. it's been two hours and I'm like
[ __ ] I I said Kristen I was like should
we [ __ ] go
should I put put a blanket in there and
she was like yeah yeah but the one
blanket that he likes is the only
blanket he'll allow in the bed I mean
he's so me already he's two and a half
and just like he's got to have the
[ __ ] one blanket and she's like it's
in the car and I was like oh okay I'll
go out and get a car and get it bring it
I bring it in and say hey buddy he says
Hi I said do you want your blanket and
he says yes
and I put the blanket on him and I said
how are you doing you okay and he said
yes and I said
do you want me to uh get in there with
you and sleep in the crib and I was kind
of like just saying it and he said
I said you do you want me to come in he
says yes and so I move so he moves over
I go in in the crib and I'm sleeping
with him actually we have a picture of
it we can put it on the uh
on the video and uh and then I and then
I wait and then I and then I'm I'm there
for about 10 seconds and he's looking at
me in the eyes and he goes like this
go away
Stick Dude and I said oh you want me out
and he says go away
foreign
left
um and he and he cried a little bit but
it's so it's it's weird how you know
managing look he's a lot smarter than I
am in a lot of ways he knows how to
manage emotions and let a lot better
than I do at least he [ __ ] feels him
right
that's the thing it's so hard to
actually know for me how I feel
sometimes
I wonder if you're like that
like it is so [ __ ] hard like you know
a guy [ __ ] is like oh something happened
boom anger that's what I feel uh do you
though what's under that scared of [ __ ]
and I'm angry about it what's under that
heartbroken sad as [ __ ] and I'm angry
about it what's under that well I'm
happy and I don't want to be happy so
I'm mad about that because it feels
better to be angry because that's where
I live and where do I live because of my
anger fear and why do I do things that
put me in fear because that's what I'm
comfortable with and I keep reenacting
trauma sad but that's the truth
because that's where I'm comfortable
I asked my therapist
why do I do things that jeopardize
myself and make me in fear and she says
because that's
what's comfortable
for you
and that's when I think
well that makes me scared
and that's when she thinks
I know dude
because that's what's comfortable for me
oh yeah and thus goes the cycle how do I
break this and only become happy oh we
gotta work through this ah
but the thing is I don't want to
because it hurts
because when we start talking about
things I mean dude retrospect will candy
coat everything Nostalgia makes [ __ ]
taste [ __ ] real nice
but what is it really dude
so tell me about you sitting on your
porch when you were seven years old
playing with the dinosaur
s
[Music]
at last
falling Sunny Frozen
Mad World
[Music]
blood from the ice Mad World
um yeah dude
and uh so
did I rip these [ __ ] these pants are
done dude I'm done with these pants man
I got them fixed 19 [ __ ] times and
now I just kid they're so tight because
they keep patching them up I'm done with
them diesel you made a piece of [ __ ]
pants
um and they're my favorite pants so
great whatever dude
one of my therapists told me that I
should [ __ ] imagine myself as seven
years old me myself on the porch and
then bring myself to my mom and my dad
and talk to them and [ __ ] make sure
that I could take care of them and then
open up literally my chest and open up
my heart physically actually because
there was a door on my chest and imagine
it and then imagine my seven-year-old
crawling in there and closing the door
on them and I know what no matter what I
do in my life he's also there too and
I'm like okay but I imagined myself
seven years old not the size of Jiminy
Cricket
so now I got this big ass lumpy
seven-year-old sitting in my [ __ ]
chest just knees up in his [ __ ] mouth
all crunched into my chest and that's
where I am in this [ __ ] you know what
I mean Trans State and I'm still crying
but I'm like hey it doesn't really fit
ah dude
all bunched up can this dinosaur
dinosaur king fit he wants a dinosaur it
doesn't fit in it
should have told me I I should imagine
him the size of a [ __ ] Mouse
seven-year-old in my chest and [ __ ]
seven-year-old in my chest
so uh yeah man
gotta pee bad but gonna ride it out
um
is he still sleeping Calvin
almost dropping my mouth right there
that's great that's great dude I want to
get I kind of want to get back on the
coffee train but I also kind of don't
want to get back on the coffee train if
you see me I don't know man people give
me Starbucks gift cards and [ __ ] of
course that tastes like the back of the
cow's mouth but I get it they're doing
things to be nice and thank you very
much fans I got meet and greets and [ __ ]
[Music]
um
oh dude they make you [ __ ] set
boundaries dude wow one thing I [ __ ]
hate is setting boundaries I'll tell you
that much you know why I want everybody
to like me and if I put a boundary on
someone and they don't like it then they
don't like me hey dude I'm 42 and I just
figured this out you know what
um
so I had to put boundaries on people
that's what my therapist told me that I
had to put boundaries on people
that was like my assignment
and one guy that was like eating in the
[ __ ] dining hall would uh
[ __ ] pull his chair out too loud
and I'm like Larry David's sitting there
I'm just like I can't how does this
bother me that much dude I'm like a
non-vet dude
I'm like a [ __ ] numb vet when it
comes to noises dude I used to go out
with this woman when I was 32 and she
hated loud noises and it always bothered
me I'm like it's just a noise and dude
[ __ ] if I don't have that now is
it a condition loud noises look that up
loud noises you can't be around loud
noises I don't know whatever the [ __ ]
it's called audio sensitory whatever the
hell dude
he would roam the [ __ ] chair would
come out it would be like all of a
sudden an elephant just
broom and I ah
and the guy's a [ __ ] Navy SEAL or
whatever the [ __ ] he actually and so he
gets up and does everything all loud
nice guy handsome as [ __ ] and [ __ ]
run and I'm oh
hey bro haha right and he'd be like and
then he would go
like a fun guy and I'm like yeah dude I
get that's the thing to do as men but
holy [ __ ] man I got a seven-year-old
inside my chest and we don't like that
but I swallow it you know because I'm me
and I don't want him not to like me and
I'll sit I'll sit with it okay I'll sit
with it
and uh
so then uh
I gotta set these boundaries you know
like two weeks in they're like you gotta
sit pounds you gotta give somebody a
boundary a day and I'm like for [ __ ]
sake all right I'm gonna give this
[ __ ] boundary a boundary
so I'm sitting there at the [ __ ]
dining hall it's just me and he's at
another table I like the guy he's a
friend of mine gets up bro I go
and I I stand up and I say hey
hey uh but he says sup and I'm like
um
could you not
uh
could you not do that so loud with the
chair when you
when you get up it's uh it's it's so
loud
and he said
huh
and I said
I gotta
I gotta put boundaries on on people
that they said I have to practice
putting boundaries
on people
and he said
that's not a boundary
and I wasn't really equipped for that
part so I said what do you mean and he
said well a boundary is like
hey
um
when you do this
it makes me feel this way
and if you keep doing it then I'm going
to have to
do something else and remove myself in
this situation I was like oh okay right
I'm saying it wrong
um Okay so
when you
um
moved the chair like that like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I didn't say that but I wanted
to but it was right I was doing it at
the therapeutically so I'm like when you
get up and do that you uh
it it's loud for me and if if you do do
that when I'm studying here and I'm I'm
reading
books telling telling me how [ __ ] up I
am and filling out the worksheets on
how much of a piece of [ __ ] I am right
and I want to write letters fictitious
letters when I'm writing pictures
letters to my
mom and dad and
that I'm never gonna send them because
it's just an exercise right as I'm
writing a letter with my left hand
two
minor child on what what I might need
from him as a 42 year old man I'm I
can't hear that I'm gonna have to go
into the other room
um and uh
and so so that's that and he said huh
okay
um well I don't want you to have to
leave the room so uh I will
I'll be more conscious of it man and um
I try I won't I won't do it so loud
and I said oh
thanks
and then it beat past and I said
I said out loud
I feel so awful right now
and and he said really and I said
yeah man I feel [ __ ] horrible saying
that [ __ ] and he said why and I said I
mean he's 40 I'm 42 and we're standing
there and we just ate
kiss poor halibut
and cereal for dessert because there's
no sugar Cheerios by the way and and he
says uh and I and he says why
I I said
because I'm afraid when I say that
you'll like me less
42.
he's 40.
he's killed people
in the ocean
he's an elite Navy SEAL
I'm a dumbest [ __ ] comedian
I talk about things like
pants on stage
and here we are looking at each other
no let me paint the picture and I don't
mean to do this in any shitty way or
braggadocious but we're both equally as
handsome dude
that's neither here nor there but I just
want you to know that
and I said I want you to like me and he
says oh well I do like you
and that was that
and me and the seven-year-old inside my
chest
finished our work and you know what
when I when I when when when we were
joking about the [ __ ] chair
beforehand like a week before and I was
like bro okay that's so [ __ ] loud
what the [ __ ] and he would go you know
um he goes like this he said he uh ice i
i he said do I really do that loud and I
was like yeah man it's it's loud as [ __ ]
you know and he was like yeah oh and he
was like do you know like who's bad at
it now there's three dudes that are real
bad at it here and he's like really and
I was like yeah he's like how do you
even know and I was like that's the mind
I got bro this is how it is for me
and he says uh oh well who's the worst
and it was him
so I said you man dude he laughed that
was a great that was great there were
such moments of levity there it was
hilarious
that's great
we were watching uh DVDs and [ __ ] we
watched what would watch uh the Adam
Sandler movie Waterboy
and we were watching that I had never
seen that movie
sucks donkey balls and so uh we watched
it and uh and of course there were like
you know some people were like it's
always [ __ ] hilarious
sucks talking balls and so I was
watching it and they were like dude a
sex scene is coming up and I was like
really I was like yeah no obviously at
this rehab they don't allow coffee so
they're not gonna allow some [ __ ] a
screen of titties bouncing around you
know it's like oh my god what the [ __ ]
dude the scene comes up the sex scene
it gets fat what the [ __ ] we look the
nurse's station with the [ __ ] DVD
like a [ __ ] dude like Hawkeye with
the arrow dude just ready for that [ __ ]
it was like you're like oh my god oh I
like you I like you go to take off the
shirt and just
nurse with the [ __ ] Hawkeye shot dude
unreal man unfucking real the nurse with
the Hawkeye shot
don't want to trigger anyone that's what
you said
hilarious don't want to trigger anyone
[Music]
um
one time I was making everyone laugh and
she came in and she was like what are
you guys laughing about and I was like
we were just making a joke I was I don't
know I was making a joke about honey
remember and she was like okay I just
don't want to trigger anyone and I'm
like
what did what did she think I was
[ __ ] doing you know
whatever
it was a beautiful time man well that's
the episode for today on YouTube if you
want the rest of the episode The uncut
episode the uh extended episode
ad free all
super extended uh go going over to our
patreon this patreon.com crystalia uh
and uh it's six bucks and you get all
the previous episodes
um that were only on patreon I think
there's like 20 now or more
um so you can go binge if it's Breaking
Bad my baby and so uh and and you can do
that and you can also get the exclusive
content and all that [ __ ] but our
patreon's popping going over
chrisley.com or uh sorry well it is on
christine.com but you can go to
patreon.com crystallia thank you guys
[Music]
thank you
[Music]